on va te faire de bing tu pourras
concours et l'année prochaine ce qui ne
fut ni rod va pas dire çà mau cité
l'année dernière j'étais motifs fini tu
vois c'est que je suis encore plus
ambitieuses ont quand même pas sûr de
passer commande
montez pas le problème et c'est tout à
fait normal qu'il n'y en ait qu'une
qu'ils soient élus sur les cinquante et
une fille une petite fille en pleurs
c'est toujours émouvant mon cher à la
mais celle là alors quelle était la
nature de son chagrin
ben écoute ses yeux l'indiquent
peut-être ne s'agit pas d'un chagrin
d'amour en fait elle fait présenter à
miss france et figure toi qu'un sur cinq
a suivi attentivement cette
manifestation pour voir ce qui poussait
ces jeunes filles à vouloir être les
plus belles alors ça a commencé au petit
matin pratiquement sous la direction de
la grande prêtresse madame de fontenay
c'était une photo de groupe
je pourrais promettre demandé fille qui
se présente ce soir à miss france c'est
de rester elle-même de toujours aussi
gentil d'être souriante et de représente
exactement la jeune fille française tant
sur le plan moral que physique
ça vous fait rien de travailler au
dessus de 50 jeunes filles comme ça dans
ces cas là je vais j'ai baissé mon pc
vous avez choisi comme ans dans la rue
non je suis très connu un lendemain tant
que je travaille au noir pour que vous
êtes reconnu parce que je travaille
avant tout aussi confuse alors j'ai très
content pour eux
vous avez accepté tout de suite oui
je lui ai mensonge comme ça ça vient des
rabattements exemple
c'est qu'ils voient tous les bruits qui
courent qu'est ce qui va être élu oui je
pense aussi qu'elle est belle au mal
qu'est ce que veulent bien
elle est grande surtout sa tranche sur
la shdm ans parce que par ap les hôtels
sont plus ou moins petit a donc c'est
toujours d'un truc il faut être grande
pour ne pas dire non patrice tu vas être
gentil ou laisser travailler bien
patrice tiens toi bien
dernière chose ça coûte de l'argent tout
de même devenir de la réunion qui est-ce
qui paie bon bah c'est le comité qui
grappille mon voyage
mais qu'est ce que ça lui apporte c'est
pour eux pour développer le tourisme
vert comme un passionnant qu'est ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'on voit le titre
mesdemoiselles s'il vous plaît vous ne
regardez voilà
ici paris cinéma des gérants de fonds
ils se croyaient bomb squad la baule
nous étions vraiment là au coeur du
problème heures qu'elle était première
réaction le journaliste et là je dois
dire qu'au début j'ai eu du mal à faire
la différence entre cette présentation
est le salon de l'agriculture ce poids
là nan sérieusement à leurs copains de
libération de la femme on peut tout de
même un peu s'interroger
eh bien ces demoiselles dans king kong
aucun rapport ces demoiselles se
retrouver quelques temps après sur les
champs elysées où a défilé folklorique
par un froid polaire
il faut souffrir pour essayer d'être
belle
l'amateur de femmes jouent non pas du
tout produit tu veux pas c'est dommage
ni l'un ni l'autre
à quoi va sacrifier à la tradition des
champs elysées quelques instants plus
tard ces demoiselles à les connaître la
consécration par l'administration en
étant reçus à l'hôtel de ville est
encore d'âge officiel s'il vous plaît je
considère comme un privilège là missions
que j'accomplis aujourd'hui et qui me
vaut l'honneur de vous écrire en cet
hôtel de ville de vous il souhaitait la
plus cordiale des bienvenues ainsi et
surtout à monsieur le président de
fontenay avant
versez
qui accompagné de son épouse
combien de temps que vous venez à
l'hôtel de ville n'ont pas participé au
concours miss france 3 vous êtes la
seule à venir trois fois ça vous dérange
pas de revenir chaque année en perdant
chaque année n'a absolument pas je ne
viens pas spécialement pour gagner je
viens pour représenter ma ville
limoges vous êtes une des rares
intellectuels de ce groupe à quels sont
vos rapports avec les autres candidates
se passe comment vous épiez les loteries
ce cas les amitiés ou pas amitié non pas
vraiment je pense pas exploitons on dit
que vous êtes déjà la grande favorite du
concours qui se savait pas quelques
personnes en ont parlé
enfin alors quand on demande à vos amis
pourquoi vous est la grande favorite a
dit parce que vous êtes la plus grande
je ne sais pas c'est pour ça j'espère
que c'est pas pour ça
être miss france ça représente quoi pour
vous présenterai beaucoup bien sûr
j'aimerais beaucoup être miss france
fait quoi dans la vie
je suis étudiante fa lycéenne parmi les
cinquante et une candidate il y avait
une majorité d'étudiantes une
agricultrice une profession gymnastique
et quelques autres de professions
diverses mellal planches s'agit de quoi
eh bien il s'agit d'un test qui va en
principe mettre en évidence leurs
qualités morales et intellectuelles
oui on le voit d'ailleurs qu'est ce que
tu vois rien
à
c'est difficile qu'est ce que vous
demande la main sur le plan esthétique
que vous reconnaissez vous quelques
petits défauts physiques il ok là je
laisse à penser à ses jeunes amis vous a
débarqué auquel j'ai pas du tout un pan
de la table nous nous du temps justement
pour que miss france se soit pas une
femme objet est bien j'estime que tout à
fait normal que s'intéresse à ce qui se
passe autour d'elle parce que le public
a tendance à juger uniquement sur un
aspect visuel mais nous nous recherchons
aussi les qualités intellectuelles
morales qui doivent se tâte bien faite
et bien pleine
exact dix ans un corps sain dans un
esprit un esprit sain dans un corps sain
par beaucoup qu'est ce que vous avez lu
comme livre point franchement je lis pas
du tout pas du tout on sait que ça
compte ça pourtant il faut mettre qu'il
faut mettre un titre à willamette vous
conseille vous avez quel degré du tout
balzac corps dont quelles sont vos
qualités morales à dire pourquoi vous
concourrez pourquoi ce concours mais je
n'explique ici d'abord ça me permet de
connaître beaucoup plus de gens et puis
peut-être d'autres pays enfin je ne sais
pas vraiment
seul je vais découvrir d'autres choses
que que ce que je suis habitué à
connaître le lendemain soir c'était le
grand moment elle allait concourir
devant de nombreux convives
au menu des hors d'oeuvre ou dessert
mais c'est que s'applique toujours de
sex-appeal remarquer le nôtre mon cher
l'inde en quelques minutes ou les
instants sur cette piste bâtiment devant
nous on va se dire les choses très
important courage à vous je suis assez
ému il s'agit de la présentation des
miss qui vont peut-être devenir miss
france ou alors j'ai moi de demander
pour le dernier pronostic en quelque
sorte on tiercé est là aussi je suis
plutôt ému parce qu'on a déjà vu des
jeunes filles ravissantes il est
difficile de faire un choix
alors je crois que le mieux c'est de
laisser la parole au jury tout ce qui
est des personnalités très importante
qui s'arrête il faut qu'on tienne bien
je cours oui il est suivi on est suivi
thoretton l'état continue continue
tangue pas pour l'instant tout va bien
oui jacques lavoie qui vraiment pas ce
que vous vous rendez vous jeune fille
lui même pas même pas mais ou pas mais à
force de parler de répondre vraiment
coupé quelques instants plus tard
patrice laffont obtenez l'interview de
sa carrière en obtenant les confidences
du jury j'ai évidemment je pourrais me
gênait pas question de regard selon
quels critères jugés vous générez blessé
plusieurs parce que je sais passablement
plastique
sur plastique il y à la façon de parler
la face la façon de se comporter d'une
jeune fille dans la vie en général
à mon grand regret des han si vous
voulez on ne les connaît pas
suffisamment pour vous je crois pour
bien les juger en fait c'est une fille
je pense qu'il est appelé à représenter
la france donc vous google de son père
rassurez-vous subsides rue les poils
manquait à l'appel
voilà c'était vraiment le moment
important moment du défilé
oui au début le jury a mangé un petit
peu puis après il a regardé ce qui se
passait là premier défilé en costume
folklorique où il y en a eu trois je
prends dans la soirée alors on ne peut
pas dire que tous les costumes soient
très beau nom il a même certaines qui
sont vraiment très désavantagé par le
costume folklorique s'effacer miss quoi
dans ses options et sauvagnon 10
gasconne
vous étiez tout un petit peu crispé mais
en dehors d'angélique ça on peut sourire
de circonstance
elle avait pourtant répété c'est une
information jusqu'à 4 heures du matin le
genre avoir un plan superbe avec un
soutien-gorge particulier au nord de
tahiti tout droit du pied droit à moitié
emballé
ça c'est le deuxième défilé en costumes
qu'ils ont ce côté jacques dufour une
âme et oui j'avais du forest institute
et miss poitou exploite au donc on peut
continuer à parler beaucoup où il ya des
raisons à cela
il semblerait que l'avis final du jury
n'ait pas plu à tout le monde
effectivement on le verra plus tard
d'ailleurs aussi la très belle miss
réunion
on peut en profiter pour dire qu'il y a
trois grand concours c'est le concours
de miss monde de miss univers et demi ce
internationale par des pays différents
c'est à dire le japon l'angleterre et
les etats unis puissent avoir écho aux
états unis la cia derrière derrière ce
qu'elle veut dire oui madame de fontenay
nous a fait quelques confidences et il
semblerait que ça va très loin il ya des
organisations politiques et des
mouvements on parle même de malhonnêteté
la mairesse n'était pas présente du tout
non je fais pas ci fais tu es très
indiquée
mesuraient leur emballage avenue forest
surconsommation de dettes au tennis
c'est carrément une superbe forêt de
jambes qu'elle on se reposeraient
volontiers volontiers et le défilé final
diderot lui il met de la sauce dans tout
ça vous dit ça reste red alimentaire
il ya eu un problème de chaussures
également et oui après le show solo ne
parlerons pas car le jury ne s'en est
pas trop ce qu'il a commencé à délibérer
c'est l eau et à vent
s'il vous plaît je peux vous demander un
premier cas la vie elles sont toutes
tellement jolie vous allez bien être
obligé de faire le faire mais ça va être
vraiment des chirons ans avec élégance
et distinction c'est la première chose
vous allez faire des malheureux ça vous
dérange pas non pas du tout la beauté ça
engendre le malheur
le jury a continué à délibérer tout
imprégné des images de ces jeunes filles
pendant ce temps les convives continue à
manger sans autre souci que d'attendre
les résultats les résultats nous les
avons attendu nous dans les cuisines
il fallait être sur le court pour avoir
les premières confidences de la part des
membres du jury qui n'ont d'ailleurs pas
voulu en dire très long dites moi on est
suivi tes pour un sur cinq pièces
qu'amis à je ne sais pas si j'attends le
droit de le dire est ce que d'autres
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est pas
moi un excellent éviter pour elle
n'aurait pas trop sérieux et trop
sérieux
ce n'est pas ma candidate quel est votre
genre j'aurais voulu une brune parce que
je trouve que il faut réhabiliter les
brunes les bleus ne font plus d'effet
elle gagne davance par espèce d'éclat
qui émane d'elle et on ne regarde pas
c'est en détail les brunes qui absorbent
plus les couleurs réhabilitation des
bruines parents bien mauvais et puis
nous revenons dans la salle car c'est le
grand moment
une d'entre elle veut être ministre s
bien que jamais sur la bonne foi dans
les annales pour de miss france je le
laisse passer que miss réunion était nul
et je le proclame miss france et 266 m
oui
sarrazin c'est vraiment merveilleux
enfin je n'ai pas vraiment exprimé là
tout de suite a vraiment vraiment
vraiment très très sûrs
suis pas très d'accord parce que nous
avait dit m les dix candidats ont
préféré d'avoir les avis très très vite
de compression et vous avez dit une fois
qu'on aura les dix noms que vous
préférez vous les 10 les plus cités je
voudrais vous parler revoir et bavarder
un peu avec elle et on n'a pas pu ni les
revoir ni bavarder avec m
j'ai voté pour die favorite qu'on devait
revoir pour discuter parce que vous
savez que j'accorde beaucoup
d'importance au verbe puis on les a pas
revus et kielce à saint-michel
finalement pas chez themis tahiti ou non
ces miss poitou gaieté du droit gones
étaient eux s'ils savent pas est tout à
fait d'accord sur la façon sur des
routes
ça y est la fille des amplis revenir
l'année prochaine
non je crois pas je laisse ma place aux
autres moi je c'est fini maintenant vous
êtes très déçu non je vais plus
oui je suis première dauphine ça fait
quoi comme effet voilà je suis très
heureuse je suis contente oui je pense
que ce sont les meilleurs qui ont gagné
et pour c'est vraiment que c'est le
meilleur qui gagne et pourquoi ça va
être plus que vous allez tu es belle
était grande
elle me plaisait beaucoup tout le monde
ya les grandes est ce que pour être
tombé de france votre vraiment grand oui
je crois dans les petites antilles
chances au départ ma fille ravissante
elle est merveilleuse je trouve que neil
une actrice elle ressemble un petit peu
a écrit d'ivoire et d'avoir tu aimes
rita loire excusez moi je suis un petit
peu émue et larme à l'oeil mais vraiment
je découvre que génère la voilà
alors on se regarde le regard dans ton
regard des frontières et la liste aucun
france vous regarde aller bonjour je
regarde devant toi regarde de 23 à ma
chérie alors avec des biens par un petit
peu lâché je serai contente
voilà c'est tout elle espère être élu un
jour peut-être miss france qui sait
youpi c'est drôle ça n'a pas suffi soir
c'est à dire mon cher à la la fête est
finie c'est pas demain tu as vu que je
suis tout mouillé oui oui qu'est ce que
tu fais pour ça j'ai besoin de réconfort
ça fait vraiment tâche mandé privé
patrice très complaisante et miss france
je vais dire miss france alain c'est la
première fois patrice je vais te dire à
la pâte voir comme ça nancy je m'en fous
je vais te dire c'est la première